Janet Janet what's that what's that
what's this her memories still being
rebooted because who you know someone
murdered her Janet could you please
locate the file for an Eleanor she'll
strop born in 1982 Phoenix Arizona USA
sure anything else
no Janet this is actually a cactus so
what do you think a ropesburg great it's
wack and you know it their number-one
crime is tricycle theft there's a bakery
attached to the precinct come on
Santiago you never would have taken that
job so why'd you even care but they
offered it to me I can't help it I'm
competitive I have seven brothers and I
was the only girl I always had to fight
for a place at the table well you're not
the only girl at the table anymore we
work and a police force full of dudes we
gotta have each other's backs okay
saying you have my back yeah I got your
back
don't smile I'm still mad at you I
thought we were having a moment when
it's over shut up Jim Halpert
a New York happy Halloween Thanks
my costumes getting a lot of attention
so apparently no one dresses up for
Halloween here I wish I'd known that
before I used grease paint for my
mustache
and I can't even take off my hat because
that I'm Hitler couple weeks probably
you can drop the voice oh this used to
get me out of jury duty in Chicago all
the time this I should gargle honey look
at these people good to see you wow
you're really burning up can I get some
money for the cab that I took over here
please
sure how much I'm not sure I looked at
the meter and it had Egyptian
hieroglyphics on it do you know the
exchange rate so should we do this oh
boy hold on
be careful what the floor and the wall
just switched okay walk very carefully
you know I find it a little insulting
that you don't trust me to handle this
not I don't trust you okay it's this
Harvest Festival is my project it's my
career on the line and I just need to
make sure that I've done everything I
can to make it work okay
it's show time good evening everyone I'm
Leslie monster and this is Nightline two
bottles of vodka is this gonna be the
weekend we finally meet six-drink amy
six-drink amy what does that mean it's
the pinnacle of the Santiago drunkenness
scale one drink aim is a little Spacey
wait what two drinks loud Amy you want
to get a cat three drinks Amy dance
pants four-drink amy is a bit of a
pervert hey check it out
and five-drink amy is weirdly confident
let's do this little man but I've never
seen six-drink amy
maybe she's the one I could actually be
friends with aka my sasquatch just water
tonight huh
designate driver yeah it sucks I think
it's awesome when someone's got to do it
right
I think it's a cool thing to do for
people yeah no I meant I meant I it
sucks that I can't do it more often
I actually prefer it to drinking staying
sober and knowing my friends will get
home safe that's my buzz hey guys good
news and bad news see that hot bartender
over there he's into me and we're gonna
bang it out the bad news is it means I
can't drive you guys home but I did call
a cab for you guys but they recognized
my number and they didn't want to come
I've thrown up in a lot of cabs so are
we good here owner you a very important
choice to make
if you blow us off you are banned from
Thursday night drinks forever yeah I'm
good with that I'll see you guys at work
peace you let's go of the 25 infants
today only one has deemed himself worthy
of a sommelier certificate oh my god are
you sure no way oh my god thank you
thank you so much everyone I think we
can agree that all wine tastes the same
and if you spend more than five dollars
on wine you are very stupid security I
just wanna thank all the people that got
me here
Norbit Pluto Nash all the clumps
congratulations to the next Indiana
master sommelier is that a - phone
so all about to do is just check in see
how everyone's holding up just bring
some cheer to these extraordinary people
cool so tell me about yourself I mean I
want to hear it all girlfriends good dad
really bad the embarrassing the
humiliating just what's behind okay well
I I was born in Pakistan raised in
London schooled in Paris but I think the
primary reason that I'm in the good
place is that I raised quite a lot of
money for nonprofit groups uh do you
ever ask your modal off the top for
yourself no no every penny was a
captured four and as I raised nearly
sixty billion dollars quite a lot of
pennies
I also dabbled in some other professions
I I was a model a museum curator and it
girl and oh I was Baz Luhrmann's muse
for a while that's quite fun modelling
that's a crazy life want to tell me
about that rock bottom you probably hear
it didn't really do it for known kichul
just doesn't fit my body I'm cursed with
ample bosom and yet you soldier on oh
this is silly
so tehani means congratulations in
Arabic and Al Jarreau means beautiful so
my full name altogether Muse
ngratulations beautiful ex-senator big
flirt you do more I'm sorry for making
fun of you in front of everybody and
also for making fun of you behind your
back
didn't know you did that but thank you
for the apology I'm not done also I'm
sorry for making fun of you during my
book club those people don't even know
you
that was uncool also I'm sorry it's okay
I get it
no also I'm sorry that I didn't take the
time to show you how to fix your mistake
come on we can go over it upstairs
Thanks
that'd be great oh one more sorry you're
about to see a drawing I did of you and
the elevator just remember I was really
pissed at the time
it's a pleasure to be here ladies I
didn't think anybody really cared about
my time on the City Council oh we do I
mean you are such an inspiration still
going strong at 82 how old is that
handkerchief well it's not a
handkerchief it's a receipt Paula hork
was pawnees first female city councilor
40 years ago and she was a huge
inspiration to me women have come a long
way in Pawnee but we still have quite a
ways to go I mean technically I'm not
allowed to reserve this conference room
without my husband or Father's signature
government was a real boys club back in
the 70s they smoked their cigars they
snapped my bra or mirrors on their shoes
to look up my skirt well I'm happy to
report that it is now a pervert free
people's club well except for councilman
decks Hart who's a self-described
pervert yeah and didn't Milton try to
kiss you well yeah things aren't perfect
all the other councilmen used to keep a
calendar my menstrual cycle are you
kidding me that is horrible they don't
do that to me do they do that to me I
once tried to start a commission to try
to get more jobs for women in city
government and they dismissed me saying
that it was because it was just my time
of the month admittedly they were right
because of their calendar man pigs all
of them you know what I'm gonna get that
Commission going because this inequality
has gone on long enough
you know what I think men are better
than women she's kidding no I'm not they
provide for us and we must obey them
because they are our masters April stop
it Leslie you'll never land a bow with
that domineering tone we must always
walk behind the mesh seedy no president
yogurt for you smart
oh don't just said doing some reading
yeah in there brother working hard or
hardly working am i right hump day sorry
Janet's functioning is my assistant but
she's a little stiff so I've been trying
to get her to be a little more casual
and conversational I'll have what she's
having
it's a work in progress listen cheating
I've been studying your file you're a
very interesting case you've essentially
only did one thing while you were on
earth you thought and wrote about ethic
yes I I spent 18 years working on my
manuscript revolt who we are and who we
are not knowing practical ethics and
their application in the modern world
semicolon a treatise on the deaths
that's the one that's the one I think
you should experience new adventures you
know do things that you haven't done on
earth right so why don't we meet
tomorrow and try out some new hobbies oh
why not
I'll see you guys tomorrow not if I see
you first
where's the beef well I - home day
you